ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion et de madame Carole
Grandjean délégué ministre délégué
chargé de l'enseignement et de la
formation professionnelle sur la feuille
de route du ministère du Travail et sur
le projet de loi pourtant mesures
d'urgence relative au fonctionnement du
marché du travail en vue du plein emploi
nous devrions examiner ce texte en
commission le mercredi 12 octobre
prochain
puis en séance à partir du 25 octobre si
l'Assemblée nationale veut bien nous le
transmettre selon le calendrier prévu
j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo qui sera
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat et disponible en vidéo à la
demande
monsieur le ministre je vais vous
laisser la parole pour présenter
rapidement la feuille de route avant
d'abord des dispositions projets de loi
je donnerai ensuite la parole à Madame
Grandjean puis je passerai aux questions
de nos rapporteurs Frédéric puisse nous
puis au commissaire qui souhaite vous
interroger nous disposons d'une heure 30
avant de vous passer la parole monsieur
minet je voudrais accueillir monsieur
Abdallah Hassani qui est notre collecte
qui remplace Dominique Théophile qui lui
est parti à la commission des lois et
donc monsieur Hassani intègre notre
commission et nous accueillons avec
plaisir
voilà
donc monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
Madame et Monsieur les rapporteurs
madame la ministre chère Carole mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs quelques mots
d'abord pour vous dire le plaisir je
vais vous retrouver pour à la fois
évoquer la feuille de route du ministère
du Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion pour le quinquennat qui
s'ouvre mais aussi abordé le projet de
loi portant diverses mesures d'urgence
en faveur du pénurie projet de loi
actuellement adopté par actuellement
examiné par donnez moi par l'Assemblée
nationale pour ce qui concerne notre
feuille de route je voudrais d'abord
commencer en rappelant qu'il y a un
objectif et un objectif quasiment unique
à cette feuille de route qui est
l'objectif du plein emploi avec une
partie du chemin qui a été parcourue
puisque depuis le début du 1er
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron le taux de
chômage est passé de 9,5 à 7,4%. et
l'économie française a créé un million
500 000 en fenêtres dans le secteur
privé en l'espace de 5 ans c'est donc
finalement la moitié du chemin qui a été
parcouru puisque nous estim avec le taux
de chômage
significatif d'un plein emploi serait
fixé déterminé autour de 5%. c'est donc
un horizon qui est atteignable c'est
aussi un horizon qui ne sera pas un seul
et qui nécessite la plus grande des
mobilisations avant de laisser place à
nos échanges et de dire au préalable un
mot sur la question de l'assurance
chômage je voudrais rappeler peut-être
les 8 chantiers qui caractérise cette
feuille de route sans jamais entrer dans
le détail de ces 8 chantiers nous n'en
aurions pas le temps mais je répondrai
bien volontiers à l'ensemble de vos
questions maintenant ou à l'occasion de
séance ultérieure si le temps devait
nous manquer le premier chantier que
nous ouvrons j'y reviendrai dans un
instant et la réforme de l'assurance
chômage c'est un texte que nous portons
que nous pensons pour apporter une
réponse supplémentaire et une réponse
complémentaire ça n'est évidemment pas
la seule à mettre en oeuvre pour
répondre aux tensions de recrutement le
chômage a baissé c'est heureux mais nous
avons encore 7,4% de chômage dans notre
pays un des plus hauts chiffres en
Europe un chômage structurel qui est
important et dans le même temps nous
connaissons des tensions de recrutement
à tel point que nonobstant l'énergie
bien évidemment c'est le principal sujet
de préoccupation des chefs d'entreprise
60% des entreprises disent rencontrer
des difficultés de recrutement et
chiffres peut-être plus inquiétant ou
significatif 30% des entreprises
industrielles déclarent être limité dans
leur capacité de production ou de
développement par des questions
relatives au manque de main d'oeuvre je
reviendrai tout à l'heure sur ce texte
relatif à l'assurance chômage il a été
adopté ce matin par la commission des
affaires sociales de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est une première étape de
franchi en espérant que la seconde soit
franchise dans les mêmes conditions pour
que le vœu de madame la Présidente soit
exaucé et que le texte soit transmis
dans les délais indicatifs qui sont ceux
que nous envisageons aussi le deuxième
chantier que nous allons mener dans ces
mais moi qui s'ouvrent et relatif à la
création et la mise en place de France
travail j'ai désigné Thibault guili le
haut-commissaire à l'emploi et à
l'engagement des entreprises
comme préfigurateur et il a la charge
d'ici au 15 décembre dans le cas d'une
concertation avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes que nous avons réunies à la
fin de la semaine dernière d'arrêter le
schéma global que doit être
france-travail et de mener tout au long
de l'année 2023 à la fois les
expérimentations nécessaires mais aussi
les travaux de concertation
complémentaire et de mise en place de
France travail il s'agit en aucun cas
d'une super structure il s'agit pas
d'une fusion de tout en tout il s'agit
essentiellement de penser le service
public de l'emploi comme un guichet
unique le plus unique possible avec un
interlocuteur le plus souvent possible
et le plus longtemps possible unique à
la fois pour les demandeurs d'emploi
pour les bénéficiaires du RSA et pour
les entreprises qui recrutent charge
ensuite à cette mission de mieux
coordonner l'ensemble des acteurs et de
prévoir une gouvernance nationale et
territoriale qui permet de cette
efficacité le troisième chantier pour
aller très vite concerne le retour ou
l'accès à l'emploi des publics qui en
sont les plus éloignés je pense à deux
sujets en particulier d'abord le public
bénéficiaire du RSA que je distingue
volontairement du public des demandeurs
d'emploi dans la mesure où seul 40% des
bénéficiaires du RSA sont inscrits
aujourd'hui comme demandeur d'emploi
c'est à s'explique tous ne sont pas en
capacité pour des tas de raisons
extrêmement légitimes d'aller
directement vers l'emploi mais certains
d'entre eux pourraient être plus
rapidement cette expérimentation qui
correspond à l'accompagnement renforcé
vers l'emploi des bénéficiaires du RSA
tels annoncé par le président de la
République sera d'abord mise en place
par expérimentation et c'est là aussi
une des missions confiée à Thibault
Gulli dans le cadre de la mission que
j'ai cité précédemment dans une dizaine
de départements que nous identifierons
sur la base du volontariat dans les
prochaines semaines pour voir comment
nous pouvons mieux coordonner l'action
de tous et ainsi renforcer cet
accompagnement un peu sur le modèle du
contrat engagement jeune sur lequel je
reviendrai dans un instant de la même
manière nous avons une attention toute
particulière pour les publics
bénéficiaires de l'insertion par
l’activité économique ou des procédures
d'insertion au sein des entreprises
adaptées et vous aurez l'occasion de
voir que le budget pour 2023 prévoit une
montée en puissance des moyens consacrés
à l'IAE pour passer de 88 à 95000 ETP et
donc beaucoup plus de personnes
accueillies en 2023 par rapport à 2022
pour 2022 le chiffre de 88000 il a il a
prévision à date d'exécution du budget
tel qu'il avait été tel qu'il avait été
prévu le quatrième chantier que je
souhaite là aussi aborder très
rapidement concerne la question de
l'accès des jeunes à l'emploi et la
formation c'est une priorité vous
connaissez le plan jeune une solution je
veux simplement dire un mot pour dire
qu'en 2023 nous reconduirons les crédits
nécessaires à la signature de 300 000
contrats d'engagement jeunesse comme en
2022 avec là aussi un accompagnement
renforcé de 15 amateurs par semaine
d'activité d'insertion de formation ou
encore de d'immersion professionnelle
afin d'aider les jeunes concernés sans
emploi informations soit aller vers une
formation qualifiante soit aller vers
une sortie dans l'emploi à date et le
contrat a été mis en place le 1er mars
2022 donc il n'a que 6 mois de vie si je
puis dire nous avons d'ores et déjà
signé 178 000 contrat engagement jeunes
sur l'objectif de 300000 et là aussi
j'ai réuni le comité de suivi ce matin
tous les acteurs étaient satisfaits de
la mise en œuvre de celui-ci et insister
sur le fait que plus de plus de deux
types plus des deux tiers des jeunes
signataires bénéficient d'ores et déjà
d'un accompagnement entre 15 et 20
heures alors même que les structures se
mettent en place et développent leur
activité de formation d'insertion
d'accompagnement pour atteindre cet
objectif le cinquième chantier est un
chantier dont on parle beaucoup ces
derniers jours puisqu'il s'agit à la
fois du de l'accès à l'emploi des
seniors du maintien dans l'emploi des
seniors mais aussi des conditions dans
lesquelles nous assurons la durabilité
et une meilleure justice de notre
système de retraite chantier que nous
aurons l'occasion d'ouvrir prochainement
puisqu'il s'agit comme la ville
président de la République à la fois
d'améliorer ce système c'est les
pensions minimales la prise en compte de
la pénibilité la question de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes mais
aussi dans l'assurer la pérennité ce qui
implique à la fois la marche dans lequel
emploi mais aussi de travailler un peu
plus à l'échelle de chacune de nos vies
ne nous appuierons bien évidemment sur
le rapport du corps qui a été rendu il y
a une dizaine de jours et sur la vie du
comité de suivi des retraites dernier
chantier que je veux citer devant vous
sachant que deux de ces chantiers sont
portés très directement par Carole
Grandjean qui reviendra en matière de
formation professionnelle et de réformes
de la voie professionnelle pour ce qui
concerne les lycées le chantier de la
qualité de l'emploi et de la qualité du
travail aller vers le plan d'emploi doit
être aussi l'occasion d'aller vers le
bon emploi et je dis parfois que le
droit du droit au travail ne doit pas
effacer le droit du travail et il y a
trois axes autour desquels nous voulons
travailler à la fois la prévention de la
pénibilité la question de la qualité de
vie au travail mais aussi la des
accidents du travail c'est un des
chiffres qui m’a peut-être le plus
marqué depuis mon arrivée au ministère
du travail nous avons chaque année entre
5 et 600 accident du travail grave ou
mortel dans notre pays c'est une
situation qui est moins mauvaise on
n'ose jamais dire meilleur en la matière
moi mauvaise qu'il y a 10 ou 15 ans de
gros efforts ont été faits mais nous
connaissons un plateau une espèce de
palier et je pense que nous gagnerions à
nous mobiliser à nouveau pour faire
baisser ce nombre d'accidents du travail
graves ou mortel je disais Carole
Grandjean viendra sur les deux derniers
chantiers qui font notre feuille de
route et qui vont mailler les prochains
mois
un point avant de dire un mot du projet
de loi sur l'assurance chômage si vous
me permettez madame la Présidente pour
vous dire à toutes et tous et je sais
pouvoir le dire en nous donnant que pour
chacun de ces chantiers et sur la mise
en oeuvre de tous
nous-même Carole et moi nos équipes
respectives nos services sont évidemment
à votre disposition alors à la fois pour
répondre aux questions pour échanger et
trouver à chaque fois que nous ne
pouvons des consensus et des points de
convergence j'en viens donc au projet de
loi relatif au marché du travail tel
qu'il a été adopté ce matin par la
commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée c'est un projet de loi qui
comporte cinq articles cinq articles
dans sa version initiale trois articles
ont une vocation essentiellement
technique et deux articles portent des
mesures particulièrement fortes en tout
cas essentielles à nos yeux ce projet de
loi va permettre c'est l'article 5 de
ratifier 21 ordonnance pour lesquelles
le gouvernement avait été bien
évidemment habilité ratification qui
permettent de les sécuriser
juridiquement qui permettent aussi je
sais la tension transporté par le Sénat
et notamment la commission des Lois du
Sénat à ce sujet de respecter la lettre
entre l'habilitation et la ratification
parlementaire des ordonnances 20 de ces
ordonnances sont des ordonnances
relatives aux mesures prises pendant la
crise du covid avec pour l'essentiel des
dispositifs fermés mais que nous
sécuriserons ainsi pour quelques
dispositifs des actions des dispositions
qui restent ouverte et une ordonnance
concerne la modernisation du
recouvrement de la contribution des
entreprises au financement de
l'apprentissage le deuxième article très
technique de ce projet de loi et
l'article 3 nous tenons compte d'une
décision du Conseil constitutionnel à la
suite d'une QPC qui a fragilisé
l'article qui sécurise l'élaboration des
listes électorales pour les élections
professionnelles et donc à compter du
1er novembre cet article est censuré de
droit et donc nous vous proposons de le
rétablir pour garantir la bonne sécurité
de des élections professionnelles du
début du mois de décembre l'AQPC était
une pubée technique sur les éligibilité
d'une catégorie très limitée de salariés
mais quand on lit la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel cette fragilisation est
intervenue sans que personne ne le
souhaite évidemment et ainsi nous
proposons de le rétablir il y a un
article 4 qui porte sur la VAE car le
Grandjean il reviendra et puis il y a
les deux articles qui sont relatifs à
l'assurance chômage l'article 2 pardon
parce que je le fais dans un ordre
inverse
aux règles les plus élémentaires du
chiffrage des articles l'article 2 est
un article extrêmement technique aussi
il autorise simplement les Urssaf à
transmettre aux entreprises concernées
par le calcul du bonus malus sur lequel
je reviendrai la liste nominative des
contrats qui ont fait l'objet d'une
séparation et qui sont prises en compte
dans le calcul de leur position en
termes de bonus ou de malus ça permettra
d'objectiver le calcul du taux qui
justifie d'un bonus dans malus mais il
faut une disposition législative pour
autoriser cette transmission de données
nominative quand bien même il s'agit de
contrats qui concerne directement les
entreprises puisqu'elles en étaient
signataires l'article est donc centré
sur l'assurance chômage effet suite à la
réforme de 2019 la réforme de 2019 vous
l'avez toutes et tous en tête avait un
premier objectif qui était de lutter
contre l'augmentation exponentielle du
recours au contrats entre 2010 et 2019
le nombre de contrats
et demi dans le nombre de CDI proposé à
l'embauche n'avait été multiplié si je
puis dire que par 1,4 c'était le premier
objectif le deuxième objectif est de
contribuer au redressement financier de
l'unédique de 2009 à 2019 avant la crise
covid le déficit annuel moyen de
l'inédit qui était de 2,9 milliards
d'euros et cette réforme ces caractérisé
à la fois par une modification du
salaire journalier de référence par une
modification des exigences pour accéder
à l'indemnisation passant de quatre sur
28 mois à 6 sur 24 mois mais aussi de la
dégressivité des allocations à partir du
7e mois pour les salariés ayant un
revenu supérieur en moyenne à 4500 euros
brut cet réforme avait aussi mise en
place le bonus malus que je évoqué dans
cette secteur particulièrement exposé au
contrats courts il s'applique depuis le
1er septembre 2022 6000 entreprises sont
bonusées pardon maluset pardon pardon
cette vilaine expression 12000 son bonus
et c'est un résultat meilleur que ce que
nous attendions qui s'explique à la fois
par la prise en compte de la loi les
pénalités les bonus ou les malus peuvent
atteindre 1% de cotisation sur la masse
salariale c'est conséquent ça s'explique
aussi par la conjoncture économique qui
justifie le recours à des contrats plus
longs et à plus de pérennité aujourd'hui
lunédique revient dans une situation
d'excellence c'est heureux et le nombre
de contrats courts proposés en embauche
et stable alors que le nombre de CDI a
augmenté et au premier semestre 2022
puis 52% des propositions d'embauche ont
été réalisées en CDI ce qui est une
bonne nouvelle pour la lutte contre la
précarité et la stabilisation la
stabilité des demandeurs d'emploi ces
règles sont prévues par un décret de
carence pris après l'échec des
négociations interprofessionnelles de
2019 et se décret de carence arrive à
échéance le premier novembre 2022
nous voulons donc vous proposer cet
article pour trois raisons prologer les
règles actuelles jusqu'au 31 décembre
2023 et laisser ainsi la réforme de 2019
qui ne s'applique effectivement que
depuis le deuxième semestre 2021 allez à
son terme et pouvoir être totalement
évalué dans le même temps nous vous
proposons de progroger le bonus malus
jusqu'en 2024 les périodes d'observation
de trois ans justifient décalage la
deuxième chose c'est que nous souhaitons
prolonger ses règles mais aussi les
rendre plus incitatives et plus efficace
pour le retour à l'emploi nous avons un
système d'assurance chômage qui est
contre-intuitif dans ces résultats je
m'explique sur les 15 dernières années
quand le chômage était supérieur à 10%
nous n'avions que 55% des demandeurs
d'emploi qui étaient indemnisables et
quand cette dans le chômage passe en
dessous de 10% nous montons à 61%
d'indemnisables alors que la logique
voudrait que le système protège plus
quand le chômage est plus important et
nous avons aujourd'hui un système qui
est considéré comme un des plus
protecteurs en Europe et qui est un peu
là aussi paradoxal avec le maintien d'un
parfois extrêmement élevé nous proposons
donc de moduler les règles
d'indemnisation en fonction de la
conjoncture et de l'état du marché du
travail les deux critères à la fois le
critère permettant de définir si le
marché du travail dans une conjoncture
favorable neutre ou défavorable ainsi
que les critères de modulation des
règles d'indemnisation seront fixés dans
le cadre d'une concertation d'où le
renvoie un décret concertation que
j'ouvrirai dans les prochaines semaines
avec les partenaires sociaux je précise
d'emblée que nous souhaitons une
application différenciée de ce système
dans les départements d'outre-mer
considérant que les indicateurs
économiques ne sont pas les mêmes et
qu'impliquer une règle propre à la
métropole serait inefficace en outre-mer
et contre-productif nous souhaitons
aussi que le montant mensuel de
l'indemnité ne soit pas intégré dans les
critères de modulation des règles dans
la mesure où nous ne pouvons pas d'une
part prendre des mesures de protection
du pouvoir d'achat et d'autre part
courir le risque d'une baisse de
l'indemnité et par ailleurs si notre
système est protecteur est plus
protecteur que la moyenne en termes de
durée d'indemnisation et de conditions
pour accéder à l'indemnisation il est
dans la moyenne européenne pour ce qui
concerne le taux de le taux de
remplacement ces règles seront donc
fixées par un décret si la loi est
adoptée d'ici la fin de l'année 2022 un
dernier mot madame la Présidente j'ai
été trop long avant de passer la parole
si vous me permettez si vous en êtes
d'accord à Carole Grandjean pour dire
que après cette concertation sur
les modulations des règles
d'indemnisation nous ouvrirons une
négociation sur la gouvernance de
l'assurance chômage au sens large et
nous avons comme objectif que France
travail soit opérationnel au 1er janvier
24 que l'accompagnement des
bénéficiaires du RSA cette opérationnel
à la même date que la convention très
particulière
soit aussi renouvelé pour la même date
que la négociation sur la gouvernance
est aboutie et permette de fixer pour
l'après 1er janvier 2024 des règles
d'indemnisation renouvelées et
éventuellement actualisée et donc ainsi
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons la suspension de la compétence
des partenaires sociaux 14 mois nous
avons des calendriers qui permettent de
mener ces chantiers en parallèle donc de
manière coordonnées avec un nouveau
cadre d'intervention au 1er janvier 2024
madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre du Travail du plein d'emplois
de l'insertion madame la présidente de
la commission des affaires sociales
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
sénatrices en complément des propos du
ministre je souhaite vous présenter
effectivement ma feuille de route celle
du ministère de l'enseignement et de la
formation professionnelle et sa
contribution au plein emploi au fond
schématiquement cette feuille de route
va porter autour de trois axes le
premier autour de la réforme des lycées
professionnels le second entoure des
enjeux liés à l'apprentissage et le
troisième autour d'une simplification
forte des dispositifs de formation
continue pour qu'il soit réellement
mobilisés à la hauteur des
transformations de notre économie la
réforme du lycée professionnel est
conduite sous l'autorité du ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
donc je n'y reviendrai pas aujourd'hui
mais elle est effectivement un enjeu
pour participer à cette dynamique le
premier élément sur le sur le champ de
la formation professionnelle que aurait
souhaité évoquer avec vous aujourd'hui
c'est celui de la poursuite de la
dynamique de l'apprentissage et ne de
notre objectif d'atteindre un million
d'apprentis chaque année d'ici à la fin
du quinquennat au fond aujourd'hui la
dynamique d'aide exceptionnelle a été
engagée et prolongée jusqu'à la fin de
l'année elle a permis malgré la crise et
les difficultés rencontrées au niveau
des
crises successives si je puis dire un
nombre de contrats succès signés en 2021
à 732000 qui a donc plus que doublé par
rapport aux années 2012-2017 une
prolongation des primes exceptionnelles
qui a été actées jusqu'à la fin de
l'année et qui vont ouvrir sur des
concertations pour les primes de l'année
prochaine ces primes devront certes
diminuer mais sans casser cette
dynamique et nous y serons extrêmement
attentifs par ailleurs cette croissance
exceptionnelle doit aujourd'hui être
consolidée optimisé nous devons
notamment veiller à la croissance du
nombre de d'apprentis préparant un
diplôme de niveau infrabaque bac et je
souhaite salut à ce titre la qualité du
rapport présentée devant votre
commission par madame la sénatrice
Frédéric puissat monsieur le sénateur
Martin lévrier et madame la sénatrice
Corinne Ferret sur la situation de
France compétences dont nous partageons
largement les préconisations donc cet
ensemble de sujets feront l'objet de
concertation amener bien sûr avec les
partenaires sociaux le deuxième élément
concernant la formation professionnelle
et relative à la volonté que nous avons
de renforcer l'efficacité de la
formation professionnelle continue pour
mieux préparer les actifs au métier de
demain nous voulons permettre au fond un
plus grand nombre d'actifs d'accéder à
des parcours sécurisés pour leur donner
les moyens de faire face aux mutations
économiques déjà en simplifiant
radicalement les dispositifs
d'accompagnement de transition faut
entre pro à CPF de transition en
transition collective effet de formation
on a du mal à s'y retrouver donc
probablement que nos concitoyens encore
plus que nous ensuite nous voulons faire
du CPF un vrai outil de réussite des
transitions professionnelles pour
l'ensemble des actifs et si le CPF a
popularisé ni à l'accès à la formation
évidemment je le salue son catalogue
doit désormais être mieux orienter vers
les besoins de l'économie et organiser
une lutte contre les fraudes qui entoure
ce dispositif avec une proposition de
loi en ce sens qui va être débattue dans
les prochains jours à l'Assemblée
nationale dispositif qui a comme vertu
d'avoir soutenu véritablement l'entrée
en formation des femmes puisque après de
50% des femmes sont bénéficiaires
utilisatrices de leur compte personnel
de formation
et 50% des utilisateurs sont des femmes
et que 70% sont des ouvriers employés et
donc c'est une vraie avancée sociale un
vrai progrès social que nous devons
consolider et orienter mieux vers des
dispositifs d'employabilité nous
souhaitons aussi avoir un vrai axe de
travail vers le droit d'accès aux
compétences de base et au savoir
fondamentaux pour rendre universel le
droit de savoir lire et écrire compter
notre pays compte plus de 2,5 millions
d'adultes en situation d'illettrisme
dont la moitié en activité
professionnelle pour donner à chacun
l'accès aux compétences de base nos
systématiserons d'abord la détection des
litrisme y compris en entreprise et nous
poursuivrons les efforts d'orientation
et construiront un observatoire de
l'illettrisme pour que les acteurs
disposent de ressources fiables et
territorialisées enfin nous souhaitons
bâtir avec les acteurs un programme
plurianiel de sensibilisation aux enjeux
de l'illettrisme à destination des
acteurs de l'éducation de la formation
et de l'accompagnement le troisième
élément de ma feuille de route concerne
donc le de la formation professionnelle
celui autour de la simplification et de
la modernisation de la VAE c'est tout le
sens de ce projet de loi dit marché du
travail qui porte à la fois sur la
réforme de l'assurance chômage et sur
celle de la VAE qui est pour nous très
cohérent c'est de réformes c'est aussi
ce qu'ils font notre philosophie
d'action si nous incitons au retour à
l'emploi c'est en permettant à chacun de
renforcer son employabilité c'est deux
réformes vient faire cette réforme et
ces deux axes là viennent donner
finalement tout le poids la VAE pour
donner un plus grand nombre d'individus
la possibilité d'accès à une
certification et donc de progresser sur
le chemin de l'emploi
ces dispositions prévues à l'article 4
en temps d'initier une rénovation
profonde de la VAE aujourd'hui il faut
savoir que la VAE ne convainc pas elle
est vécue comme un parcours du
combattant elle est elle n'est pas vue
aujourd'hui comme une troisième voie
d'accès à la qualification au côté de la
formation initiale et de la formation
continue dans les stratégies d'accès à
l'emploi elle souffre d'un manque
d'attractivité flagrant puisque avec
seulement 30
000 parcours réalisés l'an dernier elle
est finalement deux fois moins fréquente
qu'il y a 10 ans et c'est un vrai enjeu
pour nous que de la remettre dans une
disposition d'avenir qui puisse soutenir
efficacement les parcours de promotion
d'évolution de reconversion
professionnelle des actifs ce faisant
évidemment la VAE va permettre elle
aussi de contribuer efficacement à la
lutte contre les tensions de recrutement
et à l'atteinte du plein emploi si nous
voulons permettre aux actifs de mieux
faire face aux mutations de l'économie
nous devons mieux reconnaître les
compétences acquises tout au long de la
vie en ce sens ce projet de loi est à
notre sens un grand progrès social car
il ouvre à la reconnaissance des
compétences sociales associatives ou
bénévoles notamment celle des proches et
dents concrètement l'article 4 de ce
projet de loi entend lever des freins
qui entravent aujourd'hui un plus large
accès à laae et en l'état ce projet
construit deux objectifs fondamentaux
qui doivent nous permettre d'atteindre
100 000 parcours initiés par an d'ici à
la fin du quinquennat d'abord celui de
rendre l'accès élargie en intégrant les
compétences acquises dans le cadre de
période de mise en situation en milieu
professionnel et d'ouvrir cette accès à
la VAE aux proches aidants et je sais
que beaucoup de parlementaires ont
travaillé notamment sur cette dernière
mandature à la reconnaissance des
procédants ensuite je nous prévoyons de
sécuriser des parcours de candidats en
permettant de mieux individualiser en
aut présent l'accès à l'accompagnement
en amont de la phase de recevabilité
dont elle sait qu'elle est une dont on
sait qu'elle est une source de
complexité et d'abandon et en permettant
aux associations de transition
professionnelle de financer des parcours
d'accompagnement à la VAE pour les
salariés qui souhaitent se reconvertir
je compte bien sûr c'est les débats
parlementaires pour aller plus loin
encore sur ce texte mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs vous l'aurez
compris la VAE est un dispositif qui
mérite d'être reconnu valorisés qui est
non seulement au coeur de la bataille du
plan d'emploi mais aussi dans notre
pacte social et républicain je compte
bien sûr sur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs sur vous pour voter largement
ce texte et aussi ainsi faire valoir du
droit à la reconnaissance permanente des
compétences quelques quelles qu'elles
soient tout au long de la vie un droit
finalement qui soit réel et tangible au
cœur d'une de la société du savoir et
des compétences que nous souhaitons
construire je vous remercie
merci
madame la ministre et Monsieur le
Ministre et je vais passer tout de suite
la parole à nos deux rapporteurs
Frédéric puissin et ensuite Oliviero
olivierno qui commence Oliviero oui
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre c'est un
texte effectivement on l'a vu ce matin
lors de la discussion avec l'unique qui
a une portée technique portée financière
mais aussi naturellement une portée
politique donc peut-être commencer par
par la VAE ça lui est mais je crois que
des collègues il reviendront ce qui a
été fait ce qui est fait pour les les
procédants mais au-delà de ça essayez de
mieux identifier avec vous la nécessité
qu'il y a de modifier la législation
était-il vraiment nécessaire de faire
évoluer la législation où faut-il plutôt
approfondir les questions liées à
l'accompagnement au nombre de jury et
puis vous interrogez aussi sur les
moyens qu'on va consacrer à cette
ambition parce que derrière toute
ambition naturellement il y a la
question des moyens vous entendre sur la
notion de d'activité partielle quels
sont les mesures d'urgence qui
pourraient
perdurer faire aussi entendre sur un
bilan sur ces
activités partiel qui est comment la
comment vous voyez son évolution son
coût est également et puis au-delà de de
ces deux questions sans mordre sur le
champ de Frédéric mais
vous entendre sur la notion d'évaluation
de la précédente convention puisque on a
un peu l'impression qu'on passe d'une
convention à une autre sans avoir
totalement évalué la première convention
vous entendrez également sur votre
attachement au paritarisme puisque on
l'a vu ce matin avec ludique à partir du
moment où les cotisations salariales ont
été remplacées par la CSG il y a tout de
même la question de de la gouvernance
est abordé au travers des propos que
vous avez tenus sur sur de travail mais
enfin quel vision avez-vous du
pariarisme sur la gestion de l'assurance
chômage vous entendent sur ces sujets et
puis c'est hors projets de loi mais
comme je me reprendrai pas la parole
tout de même sur la question de la
formation professionnelle et de
l'apprentissage
bien évidemment le l'objectif
quantitatif a été
tenu et il faut saluer ce nombre
d'apprentis mais en même temps
l'évolution a été très forte sur les
bacs plus 3 sur les bacs + 4 et donc
tout de même ça a fait
évoluer cette notion d'apprentissage et
est-ce que
il est pas temps de faire un effort
notamment sur les métiers post-bac ou
même les métiers d'avant bas que les
métiers de boulanger les métiers de
chaudronnier ou là tout de même
l'augmentation du nombre d'apprentis je
cite pas tous les métiers ils sont tous
honorables mais l'augmentation du nombre
d'apprentis n'a pas été aussi
conséquente que les qui a été initiée et
qui était exprimé initialement et pour
dire vrai est-ce que à un moment donné
cette augmentation de l'apprentissage
n'est pas une manière biaisée de
financer quelquefois les études
supérieures je vous remercie
Frédéric puissant on va prendre les
questions merci madame la Présidente
merci Monsieur ministre madame la
ministre pour ses propos liminaires
alors effectivement je vais être
complémentaire de l'intervention de de
mon collègue Olivier Hainaut avec trois
questions qui porteront principalement
sur la partie assurance chômage la
première sur la partie budgétaire et le
budget ludique alors je vous ai écouté
monsieur le ministre hier à la
commission sociale de l'Assemblée
nationale et je vous ai trouvé bien
optimiste ou bon communicant comme on
veut ou les deux mon capitaine en toute
état de cause je dois dire quand même
que considérer quand même que le retour
à l'équilibre et je reviendrai après sur
les termes que j'utilise
de lunédique liée essentiellement à la
réforme de 2018 au décret de carence je
pense quand même que c'est un peu
excessif pour deux raisons la première
je rappelle quand même que le budget de
ligne dédik et ça nous a été confirmé ce
matin après certes la crise de 2008 qui
a plongé à l'unédicte dans une dans un
dans un dans un déficit qu'on a qu'on a
pu voir on était sur un retour à
l'équilibre du budget avant la loi 2018
et avant le décret de carence et ensuite
nous avons quand même une dette de
lunettique qui avoisine les 60 milliards
d'euros c'est ce qu'on nous a dit grosse
maille ce matin et que cette dette de 60
milliards d'euros 30% et quand même dû à
la crise covid combien de rencontrer
donc la première question porte sur le
budget d'une édic est-ce que vous ne
considérez pas et est-ce que ce n'est
pas un neuvième chantier à ouvrir que il
n'est pas tant de nettoyer peut-être le
budget d'une édic et de rami à
l'unédicte ce qui relève de
l'assurantielle et finalement d'y
retirer ce qui relève des décisions de à
savoir le point de retraite
supplémentaire des chômeurs les
indemnisations des travailleurs
transfrontaliers le fonctionnement de
Pôle emploi et l'activité partielle qui
quand même apaisée lourd sur la partie
crise covid ça c'est la première
question la deuxième question sur la
partie contracyclique alors c'est vrai
que sur le papier je pense que tout le
monde est séduit par l'idée nous-mêmes
aussi on est séduit par l'idée par
contre quand on commence à creuser c'est
vrai que c'est un peu compliqué alors
j'ai bien noté monsieur Miss que vous
aviez retiré les DOM-TOM de la partie
contracyclique parce que quand on
regarde effectivement le taux
d'assurance chômage dans nos régions en
gros on étire de 6 à 17%. donc c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué d'avoir une
règle qui puisse s'appliquer sur des
territoires où on a des différences qui
sont aussi marquantes mais même si on
enlève les DOM-TOM et qu'on reprend que
la métropole si on prend les bassins
d'emplois par territoire on sait très
bien dans le département qu'on a des
bassins d'employés sur une partie de nos
territoires et puis d'autres qui sont
bien plus en difficulté sur une autre
partie du territoire donc quelle est la
maille territoriale que vous allez
prendre pour évaluer ce côté
contracyclique et au-delà qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire côté c'est à dire est-ce
que c'est par trimestre est-ce que c'est
annuel je rappelle qu'on est quand même
en France quand on en prend une décision
un peu de latence pour que les choses se
mettent en place donc comment est-ce que
vous envisagez de construire ce côté
contraceptique je dois dire que on a été
très interrogatif même si on était
séduit nous aussi et on va pas très bien
comment les choses peuvent se mettre en
place de façon opérationnelle et enfin
la dernière partie sur le bonus malus
peut-être témoigner monsieur le ministre
mais vous le savez que on a quand même
des chefs d'entreprise qui sont en
grosse difficulté avec ce bonus malus
alors certes tout a été mis en place il
reçoivent un courrier qui les alertes
qui sont dans la branche qui va être
éligibles au mollus malus pardon pardon
des termes mais c'est comme ça que ça se
présente ensuite tu reçois un courrier
qui leur dit ben voilà dans votre
branche le taux de rupture est celui-ci
et vous vous avez un taux de rupture qui
est de 600 700%. et à partir de là vous
avez une possibilité d'avoir un recours
mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire d'avoir
mon recours d'abord il faut
effectivement saisir l'URSSAF on sait
que c'est quand même pas très simple
dans notre pays de saisir leur safe et
au-delà aujourd'hui ils savent que en
règle générale et peu importe le taux
j'insiste beaucoup
c'est-à-dire que vous avez un taux de
rupture qui est de 600% ou un taux de
rupture qui est de 250% ou passer de
4,05 à 5% en termes de cotisations
d'assurance hommage et parfois pour des
entreprises vous avez 200300000 euros
qui vous tombent dessus et que vous
devez payer c'est ça qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans les entreprises alors
c'est vrai que le texte de loi va
permettre à ces chefs d'entreprise
d'avoir la liste des personnes
concernées mais comme nous disait tout à
l'heure le vice-président de de
lunédique qui représente le Medef
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de cette liste
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire cette liste si
ce n'est effectivement de vérifier avec
le simulateur qui a été mis en place et
pour lequel ils ont pas de
correspondance donc on peut quand même
dire que une fois qu'on aura voté ce
texte imaginons qu'on aille jusqu'au
bout que le décret se mette en place on
sera en janvier peut-être monsieur le
ministre ça veut dire que pendant 4 mois
on va avoir des règlements à l'aveugle
des entreprises qui vont devoir payer
sans savoir pour qui elle paye et
pourquoi elle paie donc ma vraie
question parce que c'est quand même la
question qu'on s'est posée est-ce que le
système est vertueux
entendu qu'effectivement le nombre de
contrats à BBC on peut quand même pas
dire que c'est dû à ce qui va se passer
dans un mois peut-être qu'il a baissé de
façon conjoncturelle donc est-ce que le
système est-ce que vous considérez si je
peux me permettre l'expétion en votre
âme et conscience que le système est
vertueux voilà ma dernière question les
yeux dans les yeux
monsieur le ministre voilà au défi de
réponse à Madame la rapporte
effectivement dans la présence je suis
mise au défi par madame le rapporteur et
et
sans dévoiler le secret d'un échange on
appart avec Madame la rapporteur j'ai
presque l'impression que c'est une
courte justice privée madame la
rapporteur que vous mettez en place mais
je dis en souriant parce que ça fait
écho à cette à cette discussion quelques
quelques éléments d'abord pardon
monsieur le rapporteur en commençant par
les trois questions de Madame puissat
puis je viendrai sur la question du
paritarisme parce que finalement c'est
peut-être ce qui en découle d'une
certaine manière d'abord sur les
questions du budget lorsque j'indique
que le budget de lunédique devrait
revenir en excédent en 2022 auteur de
2,5 milliards d'euros ça n'est pas une
prévision du gouvernement mais c'est la
prévision du ludique et en m'enfort
intérieur ou en mon âme est conscience
si vous voulez je pense que cette
prévision peut-être non pas optimiste
mais peut-être moins disante et je le
souhaite finalement parce que ça
signifierait que la reprise de l'emploi
en particulier est-elle que les chiffres
sont meilleurs l'estimation qui est
faite aujourd'hui et ça ne contredit pas
votre propos et que les les résultats
financiers de la réforme pas seulement
la lutte contre les contrats mais
l'intégralité de la réforme y compris la
composante sigr participe pour 1,9
milliards d'euros 2,5 milliards de
prévisions d'excédents et que la
conjoncture économique en tant que telle
participe plutôt pour 600 millions
d'euros sont des chiffres qui devront
être précisés avec le résultat de
l'année et je forme évidemment le vœu
que ces chiffres soient durables pour
que nous puissions avoir un système
d'assurance chômage qui soit le plus
solide possible vous avez ensuite posé
la question et à travers cela de la
gouvernance de l'assurance chômage c'est
négociation interprofessionnelle au
titre de l'article L1 du Code du travail
que je me suis engagé à ouvrir auprès
des partenaires sociaux à l'issue de la
période de concertation sur la
contracyclicité je me suis aussi engagé
devant eux à l'ouvrir avec un document
d'orientation qui soit le plus ouvert
possible et le plus large possible nous
savons qu'il y a je m'appuie là sur un
rapport désormais connu quatre grandes
familles de scénarios il y en a un qui
relève de la tout étatisation de
l'assurance chômage et je n’ouvrirai pas
la concertation sur celui-ci par contre
je laisserai les partenaires sociaux
travailler dans le cadre des trois
autres et ainsi nous proposer un système
d'assurance chômage qui est respectueux
du paritarisme et je reviendrai sur
cette notion et la place qui doit avoir
dans les débats à avec cette discussion
sur la gouvernance je pense qu'un salon
de sujets que vous avez évoqué seront
ouverts notamment sur ce qui doit
relever au nom de l'assurance chômage
même si vous l'avez compris c'est la
pratique qui est la nôtre nous
considérons que ce qui relève de
l'activité partielle tout comme
d'ailleurs d'une partie de la forme de
financement de la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi au travers du
financement à hauteur de 11% de Pôle
Emploi relève mais c'est une
appréciation gouvernementale des
compétences ou du champ d'action de
l'unédique nous considérons que sur
l'activité partielle ce que nous avons
fait qui est un coup des deux tiers pour
l'État un peu plus 70% l'État et 30%
pour lunédique a permis visiter un
chômage structurel de masse et
certainement d’éviter des dépenses de
très long terme et extrêmement
importantes avec par ailleurs une mise à
mal de la cohésion sociale une
considérons aussi que quand via Pôle
emploi et son financement par lunédique
nous contribuons à la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi nous contribuons à
leur employabilité le terme est toujours
particulier et donc à baisser le chômage
et donc aussi indirectement à améliorer
la situation de l'inédit sur les
questions liées à la contracte vous avez
raison de pointer la difficulté la
territorialisation c'est cette
difficulté de territorialisation qui m'a
amené à reporter de quelques jours
l'ouverture formelle de la concertation
car j'ai demandé à nos services et à mon
cabinet de d'instruire plus avant cette
question là pour éviter des effets de
bord d'une part pour éviter aussi de
mettre en place un système qui serait
absolument incompréhensible la question
des Outre-mer doit être différenciée
j'ai parlé de différenciation plus que
de non-application et nous verrons ce
qu'il vient du débat sur ce sujet là
par contre je crois aussi comme vous que
nous devons travailler sur les
indicateurs à retenir permettant
d'entrer dans une période de modulation
de l'assurance chômage des règles de
modulation sur la durée ou sur les
conditions d'affiliation et non pas sur
le montant d'indemnité je ne suis pas
convaincu que le taux de chômage soit le
meilleur indicateur d'abord parce qu'il
est volatile et aussi parce qu'il est
très différent il y a d'autres
indicateurs sur les évolutions de
l'économie mais aussi sur le rapport
entre le nombre d'emplois des le nombre
d'offres déclarées et le nombre de
demandeurs inscrits qui a priori mais je
veux laisser la concertation se dérouler
sereinement me paraissent intéressant à
regarder par exemple de 2017 à 2022 le
nombre d'offres déposés auprès de Pôle
emploi et donc d'emplois disponibles et
passer de 50 pour 1000 demandeurs
d'emploi inscrits à 170 en l'espace de
cinq ans ce qui est aussi une des
explications des tensions de recrutement
que nous rencontrons quand on ajoute à
cela les difficultés liées à la question
de l'adéquation entre les compétences et
les besoins sur la question du bonus
malus c'est effectivement par rapport au
tomedion pour les entreprises de plus de
salarié que le bonus ou les malus et est
appliqué je précise je n'avais pas fait
dans mon propos liminaire que parmi les
sels secteurs exposés au bonus malus ou
éligible pour reprendre le terme exact
nous avons exclus les entreprises qui
étaient dans la liste S1 du décret covid
pour éviter d'appliquer un système de
bonus ou de malus et des entreprises
dans l'activité avait été très perturbé
et ils nous paraît pour répondre très
directement à votre question que le
système est vertu qu'il est vertueux
parce qu'il invite les secteurs les plus
exposés au contrats courts à
réinterroger ses pratiques là quant à la
transmission des données nominative
c'est une demande très insistante des
différentes organisations d'employeur et
donc si parmi eux certains doutes de
l'utilité d'autres doivent pouvoir
apporter une réponse à cette question
sur le paritarisme je vais simplement
dire absolument absolument
attachés c'est la raison pour laquelle
je souhaite que la question de la
gouvernance de l'assurance chômage qui
est certainement un sujet majeur à mes
yeux mais je sais que c'est le cas pour
eux soit l'objet d'une négociation
interprofessionnelle et donc tes
recherches je mets encore majoritaire
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle dans
le cadre des chantiers que nous vous
proposons d'ouvrir nous avons limité
cette suspension à la compétence à 14
mois cela peut paraître long mais à
l'échelle administrative nous savons
tous que c'est relativement bref parce
que d'une part ça me paraît convergent
en tout cas cohérent pardon avec le
calendrier de tous les chantiers que
j'ai évoqué et un point d'arrivée fin
décembre 2023 et puis par ailleurs ça me
paraîtrait être une mauvaise manière en
fait aux partenaire sociaux que de
suspendre leurs compétences à la matière
pendant plus de 14 mois pourquoi est-ce
que nous proposons nous nous proposons
de passer par la loi et d'adopter cette
loi merci beaucoup tout simplement car
si nous avons voulu enchaîner une
nouvelle période après le décret de
carence à partir du 1er novembre il
aurait fallu lancer la concertation
préalable à la négociation puis la
négociation interprofessionnelle dans la
période entre l'élection présidentielle
et l'élection législative ça n'était pas
une période politique pour tout le monde
je crois qui se prêtait à cela et par
ailleurs en terme de légitimité sur un
sujet aussi important il est compliqué
dans une période comme celle-ci pour un
gouvernement d'ouvrir une négociation
sur une lettre de cadrage qui engagerait
y compris ses successeurs nous sommes
donc rattrapés par le temps pour cette
raison là ce qui nous amène en plus de
la volonté de faire vivre une réforme
qui n'a qu'un peu plus d'un an
d'anciennes à vous proposer cette
formule dérogatoire
sur la formation
oui merci Madame le présidente monsieur
Hainaut vous m'interrogez sur au fond la
nécessité de modifier dans la loi et par
la loi les dispositifs de VAE et au fond
quels moyens nous souhaitons donner à
cette nouvelle disposition au fond la
loi actuellement définit des règles qui
sont trop rigides et on le voit
notamment par la grande perte de de de
personnes qui sont en démarche de VAE
entre le début et la fin puisque seul
10% des personnes qui démarrent une VAE
la termine que nous avons une durée de
validation des acquis de l'expérience
qui est environ de ce qui est en moyenne
de 18 mois et donc on a effectivement
une déperdition extrêmement forte des
personnes qui initient cette démarche du
fait aussi de ces contraintes
administratives très très rigide
finalement et qui ne répondent pas bien
aux enjeux de la vie de chacun qu'elle
soit personnelle ou professionnelle en
18 mois de temps votre une vie
personnelle ou professionnelle évoluent
et
modifie finalement les contraintes qui
sont les vôtres au moment où vous
engagez votre validation des acquis
d'expérience ce que nous observons c'est
que depuis 20 ans ça devait existe
désormais qu'elle a été déjà rénovée et
que pour autant son voilà ce son nombre
n'évolue pas ou voire même a tendance à
même diminuer cette volonté de donner
plus de flexibilité à la validation
d'expérience elle est aussi liée à la
variabilité des réalités sectorielles
elle est aussi la volonté d'être plus
concentré sur l'exigence finalement de
l'étape de passation de l'examen et du
jury d'examen plutôt que sur des
exigences administratives de
recevabilité qui font une présélection
par
l'inégalité ou la difficulté de
constituer un dossier de recevabilité
c'est la faute finalement pour nous
l'enjeu c'est comment est-ce qu'on
modernise ce dispositif de validation
des acquis d'expérience comment font on
est avec vous d'ailleurs on partage
cette idée que on est sur plutôt un
enjeu de d'accompagnement
d'individualisation de l'accompagnement
pour favoriser la réussite du parcours
et la réalisation du parcours évidemment
accompagné des régions qui ont la
compétence pour accompagner les
demandeurs d'emploi et notamment avec
l'appui des OPCO et les athé pro l'idée
pour nous c'est véritablement de nous
concentrer sur la capacité d'individu à
faire preuve des compétences des
savoir-faire des savoir-être acquis et
de cette capacité à présenter au jury
qui est complètement indépendant et qui
restera complètement indépendant pour
évaluer
tout ou partie de la de l'obtention d'un
diplôme c'est vraiment dans cette
proche là que nous sommes dans celle de
l'agilité et en retour aussi d'une
expérience qui s'appelle Reva qui nous a
permis de montrer à quel point lever un
grand nombre de verrous administratifs
de levier et de Fred administratif à
faciliter le recours à la VAE et
notamment sur des niveaux de diplôme je
veux dire moi un coutumé au moins aisé
en aisance par rapport aux enjeux
administratifs et je pense au niveau
Capac voir même BTS pour nos cité que
ces exemples là sur l'apprentissage
pardon je voudrais juste simplement dire
que l'apprentissage bac infraba qu'il a
lui aussi augmenté sur ces dernières
années sur cette même période que celle
que j'ai cité tout à l'heure nous sommes
passés de 180 000 à 280 000 diplômés cap
bac pro et que évidemment aucun frein
n'a été donné à l'accompagnement des
apprentis de ces niveaux là que l'accès
au supérieur a parfois aussi rendu
possible le parcours de formation de
pour des étudiants en supérieur qui
viennent peut-être de mieux pour le plus
modeste qui peut-être parfois n'avait
pas de bourse ou peut-être ont pu ainsi
éviter des jobs clients qui auraient
rendu difficile la réalisation de leurs
études et que probablement
l'Enseignement supérieur a aussi
participé au changement de l'image sur
l'apprentissage et donc à titre
personnel je souhaite vraiment montrer à
quel point je crois pas qu'il faille
opposer
l'apprentissage dans ces dans ces
niveaux mais plutôt s'attacher à ce que
l'apprentissage soit renforcé soutenu
sur les niveaux bacs et infrabach
bien merci alors j'ai 11 collègues qui
sont inscrits pour des questions donc on
va prendre un premier groupe de cinq ou
six et je passe la parole Annick Annick
Pétrus ensuite il y aura Abdallah
Hassani Monique Lubin Victor jasmin
Daniel Chassain
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
présentation et vos réponses la création
l'année dernière à Saint-Martin du
mission locale sur la collectivité
d'outre-mer de Saint-Martin dernière
année d'émission locale nous a permis de
nous inscrire dans le droit commun mais
surtout d'organiser le structurer la
réponse institutionnelle de Saint-Martin
au poème rencontrer par les jeunes
sémantinois en effet le territoire de
Saint-Martin bénéficie d'une période de
statut commune de départements de la
Guadeloupe lors de la réforme de 2007
conférant le statut de collectivité
d'outre-mer à mon territoire l'émission
antérieure m'a assurée par la Mission
locale ont été dévolus partiellement au
service de l'accueil information et de
l'orientation service créé au sein de
des services de l'administration de la
nouvelle collectivité
cette organisation à singulièrement
montrer ses premières limites lorsqu'il
s'agit de mettre en oeuvre les
dispositif d'accompagnement déployer en
faveur des jeunes dont la mission locale
était les chevilles ouvrières l'exemple
des contrats d'avenir en lançant une
parfaite illustration
au regard des dispositifs qui étaient
prévus dans le cadre du plan de relance
notamment le plan un jeune une solution
dont l'émission locale sont des acteurs
incontournables il devenait dès lors
impensable que le territoire de
Saint-Martin ne soit pas doté d'une
telle structure l'État a donc souhaité
nous accompagner dans la création d'une
mission locale sur le territoire de
Saint-Martin là aujourd'hui un peu plus
d'un an cette décision a été vue comme
un acte fort envers la jeunesse c'est
Martinoise à la suite des annonces de la
première ministre
je souhaiterais vous interroger monsieur
le ministre sur l'éventuelle fusion
d'émission locale et de Pôle emploi je
m'inquiète déjà de la résonance
de cette action sur mon territoire alors
est-ce toujours d'actualité
les territoires d'outre-mer seront-ils
concernés et si oui à quelle chaîne
on connaît très bien tout l'intérêt du
dispositif de mentorat pour
l'orientation des jeunes
projet qui est impulsé par le Président
de la République à travers le dispositif
un jeune un mentor notamment
en complément de ces outils existants il
est beau porté par les acteurs
associatifs
quelle place pourront jouer ses acteurs
dans la mise en œuvre de nos politiques
publiques visant à l'emploi et à la
formation
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Ministre madame la ministre
de votre présence
ce projet de loi est présenté comme
étant très technique en fait il est très
politique et
vous avez ça vous a déjà été dit et je
ne doute pas de de la force qui est la
vôtre de trouver toujours d'excellents
arguments mais il n'empêche que ce que
nous nous avons envie de vous dire c'est
que ce projet de loi c'est ni plus ni
moins la reprise en main de l'assurance
chômage par le gouvernement et c'est la
privation des partenaires sociaux de
leur prérogative en tout cas c'est comme
ça qu'il l'entendent nous sommes en
train de les auditionner les uns et les
autres les syndicats nous les avons pas
encore tous auditionnés mais quasiment
tous et c'est exactement comme ça qu'il
le ressentent et certes vous nous avez
donné quelques raisons mais la période
sur laquelle vous vous proposez de
prendre cette main et quand même
quasiment d'une année ou voire même d'un
peu plus d'une année
je vous avoue que nous avons du mal à
croire qu'il ne s'agisse qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'une réorientation de la de la
future gestion de l'assurance chômage
deuxième chose quel est votre définition
du plein emploi ce qu'on vous entend
quand je dis vous monsieur le ministre
madame la ministre on entend toujours le
gouvernement pardon parler du plein
emploi mais quel est votre définition du
plein emploi quand on sait
qu'aujourd'hui il suffit de travailler
quelques heures pour être considéré
comme ayant retrouvé un emploi donc le
plein emploi oui mais de quelle pleine
emploi s'agit-il s'agit-il d'un emploi
de qualité ou s'agit-il d'emplois
précaires
troisième chose pensez-vous qu'il
suffisent de d'indemniser moins lenteur
donc moins longtemps des demandeurs
d'emploi
pour qu'il retrouve systématiquement un
emploi
enfin au travers de ces questions le but
du gouvernement n'est-il pas de changer
finalement la philosophie de l'assurance
chômage
vous avez déjà commencé votre
gouvernement a déjà commencé ça a été
dit par un de mes collègues vous avez
déjà commencé par le financement de
l'assurance chômage avec la CSG
aujourd'hui cette façon que cette ce
projet de loi que vous nous proposez
démontre que l'objectif n'est pas de
faire en sorte que quelqu'un qui est
privé d'emploi puisse avoir suffisamment
de temps pour se former rechercher un
autre emploi changer d'orientation mais
retrouver le plus vite possible un
emploi futile moins qualifié et moins
bien payé que celui qu'il avait avant
et enfin Monsieur le Ministre ça n'a pas
grand chose à voir sur la même rien à
voir avec le projet de loi actuelle mais
vous en avez parlé en préambule je me
permets vous avez parlé de l'IAE
je me permets d'appeler votre attention
sur les difficultés alors là je connais
bien le sujet puisque je préside depuis
très longtemps une structure dit à eux
les difficultés dans lequel les
structures et dit à eux vont se
retrouver dans un an
si un peu de souplesse et n'est pas
accordé par rapport au pas si à eux qui
limitent à deux ans la possibilité pour
les demandeurs d'emploi de rester dans
les structures d'insertion d'activité
par l'économique les structures
d'insertion d'activité par la l'économie
sont elles aussi aujourd'hui si on peut
dire
victime de d'une amélioration de
l'emploi puisque ceux qui sont éloignés
de l'emploi qui venait vers elle ils
viennent plus trouver autre chose et
c'est bien ainsi puisque c'était quand
même l'objectif et ceux qui sont très
très éloignés de l'emploi nous
n'arrivons pas à les faire venir donc à
l'eau à la à l'horizon à la fin 2023 si
les règles sont appliquées vraiment si
on ne nous donne pas un peu de un peu de
temps pour appliquer les règles je
crains que de nombreuses structures de
l'IAE ne se retrouvent en difficulté je
profite de l'occasion qui m'est donnée
puisque vous nous en avez parlé pour
appeler votre attention sur ce sujet
très bien victoire jasmin et ensuite
Daniel Chassin oui merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre madame
la ministre alors je commencerai par
vous dire que vous avez souhaité
différencier évidemment l'estremer et je
crois que c'est une très bonne chose
parce que très souvent les mesures qui
ont été prises et ça m'a encore vu et
bien génère des conflits des conflits
sociaux et toutes les mesures ne sont
pas forcément applicables aux différents
territoires et particulièrement
outre-mer je commencerai par vous
conseiller la première chose c'est un
conseil la formation des conseillers
d'orientation psychologues parce qu'on
ne peut pas avoir des personnes qui
comme des robots oriente les jeunes
favorise l'exode des jeunes de nos
territoires pour venir où on hexagone
ici ou alors au Canada donc on doit
changer de logiciel on doit mettre en
cohérence les politiques publiques par
rapport aux besoins du territoire et
mettre en cohérence l'offre et la
demande alors lorsqu'on a travaillé sur
la précédente
mandatu je dirais la vôtre
ministre ici même j'avais évoqué
l'inorganisation des branches
professionnelles et Madame Pinko à
l'époque elle a fait une réunion après
avec tout les territoires d'outre-mer on
a évoqué les difficultés qu'il y avait
et aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
rien n'a fonctionné il est vrai qu'il y
a eu la période de pandémie et je pense
que peut-être que ça y a contribué mais
quand ils font pas été fait pour notre
territoire aujourd'hui pour les métiers
essentiels du BTP on a recours en
urgence au RSMA et sinon ce sont des
travailleurs de l'Est qui viennent dans
les territoires où il y a un taux de
chômage important beaucoup plus
important et vous avez les données et
donc je ne mens pas c'est vérifiables on
est on a un centre hospitalier
université a été en construction il y a
eu un centre hospitalier gérontologique
il y a quelques années enfin bon c'est
pas si loin mais ce sont les
travailleurs de l'Est qui sont là alors
qu'il y a un taux de chômage aussi
important sur nos territoires je l'ai
évoqué et on voit très bien que
aujourd'hui nos jeunes n'ont que les
classes sociales pour ces dans ces dans
ce cadre là donc moi tant que élu à la
fois locale mais aussi en tant que
parlementaire j'attire votre attention
sur cela vous avez voulu différencier je
comprends mais vous avez une lutte
contre la précarité vous venez d'évoquer
notamment avec des contrats mais moi je
veux une lutte contre l'exode des jeunes
vers le Canada et l'Hexagone la dernière
chose que je dirais alors parce que là
je parle de réalité
excusez-moi comme il y a quelqu'un qui
parle en même temps donc ça me gêne donc
concernant également la réforme de
l'apprentissage la formation
professionnelle moi je pense que c'est
important mais nous sommes un territoire
à vocation agricole et bien il faudrait
aussi qu'il y ait des moyens pour le
lycée agricole mais pas aussi
information professionnelle concernant
l'agriculture et les métiers de la pêche
parce que on enlève des moyens récemment
avec la rentrée dans beaucoup de
circuits mais on enlève des moyens au
lycée agricole qui alors que je pense
que pour la souveraineté alimentaire il
est important que nos jeunes et que
notre population y compris pour
l'apprentissage et pour les personnes
qui seraient demandeurs d'emploi et bien
qu'il y ait des formations pour
permettre également là aussi de
valoriser l'agriculture il y a également
un problème concernant les stages les
entreprises et c'est pour cela que
contenus du fait que vous voulez
évidemment différencier et bien il
faudrait qu'on travaille davantage avec
les lieux de stage et trouver des moyens
pour que les jeunes qui sont dans les
filières professionnelles puissent
trouver des lieux de stage parce que là
il y a une réelle volonté peut-être de
votre part mais la méconnaissance du
territoire et aussi les certaines
insuffisances qui te sont peut-être
liées aussi aux acteurs de chez nous et
aux autres diraient et bien là les deux
conjugués ne permettent pas aujourd'hui
de mettre en place une politique qui
serait vraiment favorable à la
prise en compte en tout cas des réels
problèmes dans nos territoires et
particulièrement de la Guadeloupe je
vous remercie merci Victor jasmin Daniel
Chassain merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre madame la ministre
tout d'abord je me réjouis de la réponse
que vous avez fait au rapporteur Olivier
Hainaut concernant
concernant le pari tarisme que vous
souhaitez enfin si bien compris
privilégié et c'est ce que nous
souhaitons ensuite 4 questions très
rapide concernant l'insertion des
entreprises adaptées notamment en milieu
rural on a des Entreprises Adaptées mais
on a des difficultés pour faire former
ces gens parce que ils ont un petit
salaire et c'est donc pour la pour la
mobilité et je pense que ça c'est c'est
très important on a des difficultés à
trouver des emplois
deuxièmement concernant la question qui
a posé mon collègue concernant le
tutorat je pense que les personnes que
vous souhaitez maintenir dans l'emploi
et notamment les seniors mais ce serait
important qu'ils puissent avoir par
exemple des retraites à mi-temps mais
aussi qui puissent avoir qui puisse être
tuteur
faut avoir un mentorat pour des jeunes
troisième question très rapide
l'apprentissage c'est une méthode
d'excellence et je pense que elle est
elle a une image maintenant qui commence
à changer c'est une bonne chose
l'objectif d'un million c'est très bien
mais on a des difficultés déjà il y a
des difficultés pour trouver des stages
et si vous diminuez la prime est-ce que
vous n'aurez pas des difficultés pour
augmenter l'apprentissage enfin dernière
question concernant la VAE je pense que
la VAE est très
important pour former les aides à
domicile on va en avoir énormément
besoin puisque la dépendance augmente
énormément entre 2020 et 2040 et je
pense que ça c'est bien ces personnes
ont besoin d'être reconnues et de leur
proposer des formations et en même temps
je pense que au niveau du médico-social
pourquoi pas proposer de l'apprentissage
ce qui n'existe allait à l'état
homéopathique actuellement merci
le ministre merci madame la Présidente
pour ce qui concerne les questions de
Monsieur Chassin et de Monsieur Hassani
sur le mentoral tutorat l'apprentissage
ou la VAE Carole Grandjean sera plus à
même de vous répondre sur les chantiers
qu'elle suit très directement sur les
questions posées par les autres
sénateurs pour répondre très directement
à Madame Petrus sur la perspective d'une
fusion Pôle Emploi mission locale elle
n'existe pas où elle n'existe plus elle
a été pensée ça n'est pas notre objectif
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que la création
de France travail ça n'était pas une
fusion de structure et donc nous
considérons que ça n'est pas opportun
nous devons renforcer les partenariats
nous devons faire converger les
différents acteurs sur la qualité du
diagnostic sa précocité plus diagnostic
est fait tôt et plus vite les personnes
retournent à l'emploi ou accèdent à
l'emploi nous devons être aussi d'accord
sur les questions d'orientation quand
j'ai orientation ça n'est pas
orientation scolaire mais plutôt
orientation prescription d'action de
d'insertion de formation et
d'accompagnement mais ça ne se crée pas
ça ne s'accompagne pas de fusion des
structures donc soyez rassurer vous
pouvez rassurer la mission que vous avez
cité en particulier madame Lubin a
évoqué plusieurs sujets d'abord sur la
question de l'assurance chômage non ça
n'est pas une reprise en main je vous
confirme que 14 mois c'est un peu
supérieur à un an mais ça n'est pas une
reprise en main ça n'est pas notre
volonté et si c'est notre volonté je
n'ouvrirai pas une négociation
interprofessionnelle sur la gouvernance
et sur la place du paritarisme il
suffirait si je puis dire et sous
réserve évidemment que le parlementaire
en soit d'accord de modifier les règles
par la loi ce n'est pas notre objectif
et comme vous avez vu comme vous l'avez
entendu tout à l'heure dans les
différents scénarios soumis à la
négociation je n'ouvrirai pas celui sur
la l'étatisation de l'assurance chômage
donc nous sommes dans une période
provisoire pour les raisons que j'ai
évoquées à la fois la transition vers un
nouveau système global et le problème de
calendrier lié au renouvellement des
règles du décret de carence
vous me demandez ce que signifie le Pôle
Emploi le Pôle Emploi pardon le plein
d'emploi si je vais en faire une
définition totalement politique je vous
renverrai au Préambule de la
Constitution de 46 qui dit chacun a
droit à un emploi et c'est ce qui guide
ce que je fais quotidiennement ce que
nous faisons quotidiennement en
considérant qu'elle nul n'est-il
d'employable d'où les efforts que nous
faisons en matière d'insertion par
l'activité économique d'insertion des
personnes en situation d'handicap
d'accompagnement des bénéficiaires du
RSA si je devais retenir des chiffres
peut-être plus facile à mesurer que
l'affirmation d'un préambule c'est
d'après les économistes pour la France
un taux de chômage autour de 5% et c'est
aussi la progression du taux d'emploi
nous pouvons je crois tous nous
féliciter qu'en 5 ans le taux d'emploi
est progressé trois points et ça me
permet d'ailleurs de dire qu'il n'a pas
de grande démission dans notre pays nous
n'avons jamais été aussi nombreux en
proportion à travailler et c'est heureux
parce que derrière le travail c'est un
revenu c'est de l'autonomie c'est de
l'émancipation c'est aussi de la dignité
et en cela cette valeur du travail est
au cœur de ce que nous faisons
sur la question de l'incitation à la
reprise d'emploi par la diminution de la
durée maximum d'indemnités il se trouve
que toutes les études qu'on verra dans
ce sens avec des taux de retour à
l'emploi qui sont très forts au début de
la période d'indemnisation qui baisse
progressivement et qui remonte à la fin
des périodes d'indemnisation et le but
mais j'ai toujours dit que ça n'était
pas le seul objectif le seul outil c'est
d'accélérer tout cela et de permettre se
retourner à l'emploi enfin
vous avez évoqué la question de l'IAE je
veux vous rassurer mais en même temps
vous dire que je ne partage pas tout de
ce que vous avez dit d'abord vous
rassurer car comme je l'ai indiqué les
moyens consacrés à l'IAE vont augmenter
de 85 millions par rapport à l'exécuté
2022 l'année prochaine c'est une bonne
chose nous renouvelons le pic qui a eux
ce qui était financé par le plan de
relance mais nous le renouvelons en
droit commun en l'augmentant il va
passer de 85 à 100 millions d'euros en
plus du milliard 3 que j'évoque pour
l'insertion par contre j'ai une
difficulté avec l'idée que les les
bénéficiaires en tout cas les personnes
accompagnées dans le cadre de l'IAE
puisse
dans ces systèmes au-delà de deux ans
une difficulté parce que je crains
l'installation dans ce type de système
nous l'avons ouvert nous avons ouvert
cette possibilité par le CDI insertion
mais qui est réservé aux salariés des
structures d'insertion âgées de plus de
57 57 ans et demi il est aussi ouvert
dans certaines expérimentations je pense
à l'expérimentation convergente qui est
portée notamment par Emmaüs défi avec
jusqu'à 3 ans parce que les publics
concernés sont vraiment extrêmement
éloignés de l'emploi et très cabossé par
la vie mais en faire un principe général
nous pose une difficulté donc nous
sommes ouverts à travailler sur des
mixes à travailler sur l'accompagnement
je regarderai avec vous si vous le
souhaitez les situations vous évoquez
mais en tout cas pas forcément faire un
principe général madame jasmin je l'ai
dit sur sur les questions d'organisation
de branches que vous avez évoqué en
outre-mer je ne connais pas le sujet
donc je ne vais pas vous répondre comme
cela mais c'est moi le temps de regarder
et puis si on peut en reparler ensemble
ça ça sera plus simple parce que je le
découvre avec vous donc je ne vais pas
prendre le risque de vous dire de vous
dire des bêtises je je crois avoir fait
à peu près le tour à l'exception des
sujets d'apprentissage
il nous reste 20 minutes avant
d'accueillir le ministre Jean-Christophe
le message écoute simplement répondre
déjà à Monsieur Hassani et sa question
concernant le mentorat à dire que
l'accompagnement des jeunes vers les
dispositifs de formation est
effectivement extrêmement important
partout sur tous les territoires et j'ai
envie de dire j'ai envie de vous parler
de d'une démarche qu'on a eu dans le
cadre de la prépa apprentissage qui
concerne des personnes plus éloignées de
formation des dispositifs de l'emploi
qui ont entre 16 et 29 ans nous avons
travaillé vraiment dans cet état
d'esprit en encourageant les structures
à personnaliser l'accompagnement pour
ajuster au mieux par rapport aux jeunes
son besoin de de cheminée finalement et
de préparer le projet qui est le sien et
sa capacité à entrer dans une formation
en apprentissage un emploi le mentorat
c'est pas un conseiller au fond c'est un
rôle modèle c'est quelqu'un qui est
inspirant quelqu'un qui va de manière
bienveillante vous aider à dessiner un
parcours vous orienter à préparer votre
projet et au fond je voudrais vous
rappeler le dispositif un jeune à mentor
qui renforce l'appui à l'apprentissage
et qui j'espère se développera au sein
de la voix professionnelle en tout cas
moi personnellement et tout mon
ministère nous souhaitons pour suivre
cette dynamique et cet engagement
également des entreprises pour mieux
accompagner tous les jeunes de la
République le deuxième réponse que je
voudrais faire c'est Madame jasmin
autour de l'apprentissage dans le lycée
agricole et je vous dis que celui-ci a
bénéficié de l'augmentation générale du
nombre d'apprentis je voudrais quand
même rappeler que secteur agricole
bénéficie de l'exonération à la taxe
d'apprentissage mais qu'il a pleinement
bénéficié des aides de l'État monsieur
Chassin je voudrais revenir sur l'idée
que j'exprimais tout à l'heure en
présentation sur notre ferme volonté
d'accompagner le développement de
l'apprentissage encore notre objectif
visant un million d'apprentis va
évidemment dans ce sens là et que nous
sommes bien sûr conscients que l'effort
est collectif pour cela que les
entreprises évidemment s'engagent dans
l'accompagnement de ces jeunes et les
fait cheminer dans la culture monde de
l'entreprise et l'apprentissage d'un
emploi et que évidemment l'état
accompagne aussi au travers des coûts
comme des aides employeurs ce chemin de
l'apprentissage vers l'insertion
professionnelle donc nous sommes
évidemment tout à fait engagés pour
poursuivre cette dynamique de
l'apprentissage juste un mot sur la VAE
des aidants et dire à quel point pour
nous la VAE le fait qu'elle puisse
devenir un véritable outil dans le cadre
des parcours d'accès à l'emploi de
promotion de reconversion
professionnelle est important dire que
la VAE peut également permettre
l'acquisition de blocs de compétences et
que concernant les aidants comme tous
les autres candidats à lave ceci
pourront accéder à des blocs de
compétences donc à s'orienter à l'issue
de la pro de VAE vers une action de
formation initiale ou continue qui leur
permettra d'accéder à l'entièreté de la
certification dire que cette VAE elle
est aussi en articulation avec les
dispositifs de formation et leur
permettra de réduire aussi le temps de
formation nécessaire au strict minimum
et de faire reconnaître les compétences
déjà à acquises des compétences des
savoir-être des savoir-faire qu'elles
ont déployées dans le cadre de leur dans
leur réalisation des dons
très bien alors enfin accélérer un peu
et les abeilles Doisneau remontent
merci madame la Présidente alors moi je
vais très rapide parce que j'étais
missionné par Jocelyne gilet pour poser
une question sur justement les aidants
alors je sais pas si elle veut avoir des
explications supplémentaires en tout cas
moi je passe la main du coup puisque les
revenus vraiment de penser mon oui merci
ma présidente monsieur le ministre donc
la feuille de route du gouvernement donc
vise à plein d'emploi on a bien entendu
à 5% d'ici la fin du mandat ce plan se
combine c'est bien avec les
recommandations européennes dans le
cadre du plan d'action du socle européen
des droits sociaux qui visent une
augmentation du taux d'emploi 68 18%
d'ici 2030 merci de faire d'écouter
mais le contexte global au sein duquel
vous voulez lancer ces réformes à
changer il ne vous a pas échappé que la
BCE comme la fête d'ailleurs a décidé de
revoir cette eau directeur à la hausse
or si on se penche sur le rapport de
banque de la Banque des règlements
internationaux et même sur les dires du
FMI cette hausse des taux directeurs
pour votre un ralentissement de
l'économie qui entrainera une hausse du
chômage voir une récession comme le
crâne la directrice de l'OMC dans un tel
contexte il faut m'expliquer comment
vous combiner vos réformes à la
politique monétaire de la BCE ne prenez
vous pas le risque de créer une société
du plein emploi de piètre qualité que
les travailleurs seraient obligés
d'accepter tant du fait de la
conjoncture économique que des réformes
structurelles actuelles dont toutes
bourse pousse les travailleurs à
renoncer à l'aspiration d'un emploi de
qualité donc ma question c'est comment
pouvez-vous espérer une hausse de la
production et du taux d'emploi en France
dans les prochaines années via vous
réformes alors même que la politique
monétaire de l'Union européenne va
semble-t-il totalement à l'encontre de
ce projet fleurs quand même avec le
risque de récession et questionières
parce que je l'ai posé à une édit qui
m'a dit que c'était à vous qui fallait
que je la pose où en est donc le rapport
sur le non recours à l'assurance chômage
promis par l'article 62 de la loi du 5
septembre 2018 sur la liberté de choisir
son avenir professionnel qui devait nous
être remis fin 2020 et dont nous a dit
récemment que ça serait début 2022 je
crois qu'on est presque à la fin 2022
donc ce rapport quand ce rapport
sera-t-il publique merci merci Xavier
c'est pas une obligation il y en a qui
sont qui sont passés dans
alors oui madame la présidente Madame et
Monsieur et Monsieur les ministres vous
l'avez rappelé en 5 ans on a eu un taux
de chômage qui a baissé de façon inédite
9,5 à 7,4 et on constate également dans
le même temps une hausse de l'activité
et du taux d'emploi ce résultat
évidemment qui est perfectible et on
souhaite tous et le fruit de réforme
mené notamment pendant les les cinq
dernières années notamment en faveur de
l'insertion des personnes les plus
éloignées de l'emploi à la fois on a un
taux une hausse du taux de l'activité et
du taux d'emploi et dans le même temps
on a un certain nombre de secteurs et
qui se sont élargis qui n'arrivent plus
à recruter vous l'avez rappelé le
chiffre de 60% d'entreprises qui ont des
difficultés aujourd'hui pour pour
recruter vous lavez récemment indiqué et
je crois que ça fait parler y compris
dans dans cette salle le terme de de
plein emploi et désormais à portée de
main et donc c'était effectivement aussi
un du président de la République lors de
la campagne présidentielle pour y
parvenir vous avez présenté
effectivement les 8 chantiers le 12
septembre dernier moi je voudrais
revenir principalement sur une
problématique sur l'insertion des jeunes
puisque
on remarque que notre pays le taux
d'emploi se tenant emploi est plus
faible pour les jeunes que la moyenne
pour les moins de 25 ans et c'est
d'ailleurs le cas que nous retrouvons
également pour les seniors ils doivent
et vous laver précisé lors de la
présentation de ces 8 chantiers faire
l'objet d'une attention toute
particulière alors ma question elle est
double Madame et Monsieur les ministres
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser le
détail des actions que vous souhaitez
mettre en place pour pallier à la fois
difficulté de recrutement et de garantir
un meilleur accès à l'emploi pour ces
jeunes qui sont éloignés de l'emploi
merci Alain Milon
oui merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur mise je voudrais d'abord faire
un constat monsieur ministre vous avez
commencé par la présentation de votre
projet de loi en disant qu'il y avait
très peu d'articles c'est excellent
c'est très bien pour nous pour le
Parlement à une condition c'est qu'il
n'y a pas une augmentation exponentielle
du nombre d'articles additionnels ou
présenté par l'Assemblée nationale ou
par le Sénat ou même comme c'est souvent
le cas par le gouvernement ça c'est le
premier point deuxième point dans dans
cette proposition il y a la ratification
d'un nombre assez conséquent
d'ordonnance
il serait souhaitable dans l'avenir que
les ordonnances ne s'imposent pas au
Parlement et que le Parlement puisse
jouer son rôle législatif à fond de
coopération avec le gouvernement et donc
les menaces d'ordonnance comme les
menaces de 49-3 ne sont pas les
bienvenus maintenant je vais vous poser
la question c'est une question sur la
formation professionnelle des IPA on m'a
posé la question hier j'en profite
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance de vous avoir
sous la main
pour faire une formation dans les IPA
infirmières en pratique avancée il faut
être infirmière avoir exercé 10 ans son
métier et la formation dure 2 ans il se
trouve que dans le cadre de cette
formation elle n'est pour l'instant tout
au moins en région provençale-côte
d'Azur financé que la première année que
peut-on faire pour qu'elle soit financée
les deux ans
Pascal grenier
c'est même la présidente monsieur le
ministre madame la ministre moi je
voudrais connaître l'articulation
concernant l'accompagnement des
bénéficiaires du RSA avec les
départements est-ce que c'est parce que
c'est quand même la compétence de
départements sur l'insertion est-ce que
vous allez demander un accompagnement
encore plus important sans donner les
moyens parce que je peux vous dire que
là enfin beaucoup de départements sont
déjà extendes sur sur les finances
est-ce que vous pensez sortir en fait du
dispositif bonus malus comme vous l'avez
fait pour les entreprises très
concernées par la crise sanitaire des
entreprises qui subissent à plein les
conséquences de la crise énergétique et
de la hausse des matériaux
pour les accidents du travail est-ce que
on pourra mais ça c'est peut-être pas
tout de suite une réponse mais ce qu'on
pourra avoir
je dirais
une synthèse par rapport aux derniers
textes qu'on avait fait et notamment du
document unique d'évaluation des risques
professionnels de savoir s'il y a eu
quand même une avancée ou pas et là où
ça pêche vous n'avez pas parlé des
personnes handicapées peut-être que
c'est pas important et puis enfin sur la
prime la prime apprentissage j'ai appris
l'apprentissage je peux vous dire que si
vous diminuez les primes apprentissage
vous allez avoir une baisse parce que à
chaque fois qu'il y a eu une opération
de cette façon à chaque fois il y a les
apprentis ne sont plus là
Corinne Corinne Corinne Ferrer oui merci
Monsieur valerenberg Madame Ferret
merci merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Ministre madame la ministre
de répondre à nos questions le miennes
vont plutôt s'adresser à madame la
ministre sur la formation
professionnelle et je commencerai par
l'apprentissage vous avez rappelé le
rapport que nous avons commis avec mes
collègues Frédéric puissant et Martin
lévrier sur France compétences le titre
que de notre corps c'est France
compétences face à une crise de
croissance et je voulais rappeler
interpellé les ministres que vous êtes
et vous madame la ministre en
particulier sur les moyens insuffisants
de France compétences à ce jour et votre
ambition étant d'augmenter le nombre
d'apprentis à un million j'ose espérer
que des propositions seront faites dans
le cadre du projet de loi de finance
pour augmenter la contribution ou la
dotation de l'État à France compétences
pour remplir totalement son rôle
toujours sur le l'apprentissage cela a
été dit vous avez indiqué que en ce qui
concerne les niveaux de diplôme bien des
efforts seront fait y compris sur les
playbacks et juste bac parce que
effectivement il ne faut pas
il ne faut pas il ne faudrait pas
opposer les différents niveaux de
qualification
au travers de cette filière de formation
que une filière qui me semble tout à
fait intéressantes et il y a des efforts
à faire également de la même façon
j'entends les remarques sur la prime
versée aux entreprises pour autant je
veux alerter aussi un million de de
contrats d'apprentissage il ne faudrait
pas que parmi ces contraintes
d'apprentissage et bien il est des CDI
déguisés parce que l'aide est
significative pour les entreprises mais
il faut trouver un juste équilibre pour
ne pas aller au-delà une question
concernant le CPF
bon parce que ça va mieux en 10 ans vous
év la volonté de lutte contre la fraude
j'imagine que c'est la fraude au centre
de formation ou soit disant centre de
formation qui propose des formations et
que ça n'est pas la fraude aux
utilisateurs qui auraient recours via le
CPF à une aide financière qui ne se
justifierait pas parce que les centres
de formation on va les organismes soit
disant de formation qui font des offres
complètement
démesurées pour pas dire excessive en
direction des potentiels utilisateurs là
oui on sait qu'il y a déjà de la fraude
qui commence enfin une question très
précise madame la ministre concernant
l'accès au savoir de base vous avez
évoqué la mise en place d'un
observatoire de l'illettrisme je voulais
voir connaître la différence
ou qu'elle ce que cela apporterait de
plus que l'Agence nationale de lutte
contre l'illettrisme qui existe déjà qui
est en place et qui proposent de
nombreuses actions et accompagnement
alors je signe avec quelques secondes
merci madame la Présidente désolé d'être
arrivé en retard mais j'étais aussi en
audition moi c'est sur les aidants je
voudrais juste revenir savoir si vous
les avez auditionné parce que moi je
l'ai fait et certains sont un peu
inquiets que vous puissiez des enfermer
un peu dans une VAE vers les soins et
voilà donc je voudrais savoir ce qu'il
en est réellement merci
c'était parfait
non non
alors
on aura l'occasion
qui commence monsieur le ministre merci
madame le Président pour répondre à
Madame quand c'est mon tous les autres
pays européens ont des prévisions de
taux de chômage entre 3 et 4% et ils ont
des prévisions économiques qui sont
souvent plus dégradées que notre donc je
ne pense pas que l'objectif de plein
emploi ne dépendent que de la
conjoncture il faut mobiliser l'ensemble
et je suis persuadé que nous pouvons y
arriver malgré ces incertitudes sur le
la question du rapport sur le non
recours à l'assurance chômage il a été
transmis à ma prédécesseur qui a demandé
à nos services de compléter un certain
nombre de parties de ce rapport
notamment sur les causes du non recours
le rapport m'a été adressé à la fin de
la semaine dernière et donc il sera
transmis au Parlement dans les jours qui
viennent tout simplement et ainsi ça
fera droit d'ailleurs un amendement
adopté par la commission des affaires
sociales de l'Assemblée hier et un
centre de questions qui ont pu mettre
posé par ailleurs pour répondre aux
questions de Monsieur yakovelli sur la
question des tensions de recrutement et
de ces difficultés que mettons nous en
œuvre à la fois la réforme de
l'assurance chômage que j'ai évoquée
mais j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises que
ce n'était le seul outil la formation
depuis octobre 2021 nous mobilisons un
milliard 4 pour former les demandeurs
d'emploi et dans le cadre du plan de
réduction des tensions et ainsi les
amener les raccompagner vers l'emploi
cela a permis le retour à l'emploi de
250 000 demandeurs d'emploi de longue
durée sur un nom ce qui est une très
bonne nouvelle pour les entreprises qui
recrutaient mais encore meilleures
nouvelles pour des hommes et des femmes
qui étaient très durablement éloignés de
l'emploi et qui retrouve un six pieds
dans la vie active et je le répète à
nouveau dans l'autonomie nous mettons en
œuvre avec Pôle emploi des actions de
rencontre de communication des jobs
dating je suis convaincu que dans vos
départements respectifs vous avez tous
vu cette multiplie cette multiplication
d'opérations et nous essayons vraiment
de tenir tous les bouts de cette
équation pour avancer le plus possible
dans quelques jours j'aurai l'occasion
d'annoncer la phase 2 du plan de
réduction des tensions de recrutement
j'ai demandé à Pôle emploi de travailler
sur l'identification de liste de Viviers
de demandeurs d'emploi pouvant être très
rapidement mobilisés soit des demandeurs
d'emploi de très courte durée parce que
nous savons que plus la période est
courte plus en plus l'employabilité est
grande soit des domaines d'emploi ayant
des compétences des qualifications et
qui au prix d'une formation très courte
peuvent être à nouveau mobilisées j'ai
demandé à ce que ce soit fait non pas au
niveau national ou régional parce qu'on
arrive vite sur des listes de 10000 ou
fin de dizaines de milliers ou centaines
de milliers de personnes mais agence par
agence sauf considère plus efficace
d'identifier sans 150 200 personnes très
facilement employables à l'échelle d'une
agence pour les employeurs du bassin
plutôt que à l'échelle de 80000 ou
100000 au niveau national et peut-être
même plus on va continuer à actionner
tous ces leviers et pour ce qui concerne
les plus jeunes c'est aussi le CEG que
j'ai évoqué et la volonté de ne laisser
personne sans solution et de faire
diminuer considérablement le nombre de
Nice
anglais je dis affreux parce que c'est
un acronyme pas parce qu'il est anglais
mais qu'on utilise pour qualifier ce qui
sont sans emploi ni formation
sur ce que monsieur le sénateur Milon a
évoqué nous ferons tout monsieur le
sénateur pour que le gouvernement ne
propose pas de l'article additionnel je
peux par contre d'ores et déjà vous dire
qu'un certain nombre de dispositions
sont été évoquées par la commission des
affaires sociales de l'Assemblée peuvent
donner lieu à quelques articles
additionnels mais qui sont utiles
notamment lorsqu'il s'agit de faire en
sorte que l'abandon de poste en termes
d'accès indemnisation soit considéré
comme une démission plutôt que comme un
simple licenciement pour faute les
délais d'indemnisation ne sont pas les
mêmes tout en préservant la possibilité
d'accompagner celles et ceux qui
abandonnent un poste pour des questions
de sécurité ou de mise en danger ça peut
malheureusement arriver même si c'est
aujourd'hui marginal sur la question des
ordonnances je partage je l'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire à plusieurs
reprises devant votre assemblée là nous
sommes sur une ratification d'ordonnance
21 que le Parlement avait dans le pour
lesquelles pardon la méditation avait
toujours été votée par le Parlement
sinon nous ne serions pas l'étape de
ratification par contre nous veillons à
ce que cette ratification soit par le
commentaire pour que
pour que ça puisse être
Parlement madame sénatrice
dans sa loi travail qu'on a ratifié je
m'en souviens aussi ensuite sur les
questions d'IPA nous allons essayer de
vous apporter des réponses mais je n'ai
pas d'éléments peut-être que Carole
Grangeon aura si jamais ça n'était pas
le cas nous les rechercherons pour me
répondre à Madame Grigny d'abord sur la
question des personnes handicapées
franchement dire que c'est pas important
non non j'ai évoqué les entreprises
adaptées j'ai évoqué les personnes les
plus éloignées de l'emploi et tout à
fait directement je considère que les
personnes les plus éloignées de l'emploi
peuvent l'être du fait de handicap du
fait d'un éloignement du fait de
difficultés sociales et je partage même
idée qu'on chaque fois qu'on peut mixer
les solutions c'est bien aussi je prends
le suivi à l'envers mais les plateformes
d'emploi accompagnées qui aident au
maintien de l'emploi de personnes
handicapées en si un contrat de travail
à mon sens doit être ouverte aussi aux
personnes les plus éloignées
bénéficiaires du RSA parce qu'au-delà
mais parce que au-delà de la sign d'un
contrat de travail l'accompagnement
après la signature est aussi important
dans ce cas là pour les entreprises
adaptées le budget progresse le pic qui
a eu mobilisé nous avons parfois un
problème de consommation de crédit sur
la formation des personnes en situation
de handicap salariés de structure
adaptée nous avions 34 millions d'euros
ouverts en 2022 seul 10 sans consommer
mais vraiment c'est tout azimut que l'on
doit mobiliser pour pouvoir avancer et
permettre d'offrir un maximum de
solutions mais soyez assuré que c'est
une priorité et d'ailleurs le hasard du
calendrier fait que ce matin avec CEDIA
Dario sec nous travaillons justement sur
la feuille de route emploi et handicap
et dans le même temps sur le projet
stratégique de l'agfip avec eux à
l'occasion d'une réunion à trois parce
que ça nous paraît mieux de coordonner
les choses sur
l'accompagnement des bénéficiaires du
RSA 1000 fois oui avec les départements
l'objectif est de le faire dans le cas
de leur compétences plutôt à iso-budget
mais avec eux et les premières premières
personnes que nous avons rencontré
Thibault guili et moi-même pour lancer
cette expérimentation
justement l'ADN et nous travaillons
aussi avec la DF pour la sélection des
territoires d'expérimentation donc c'est
vraiment très coordonné et je ne
souhaite pas que ce soit aussi une
remise en cause de la répartition des
compétences des uns et des autres sur le
bonus malus d'abord rappeler que par
secteur concerné les sept secteurs c'est
d'un point de vue macroéconomique neutre
puisque le bonus compense le malus c'est
préparer pour être neutre est-ce qu'on
va ouvrir est-ce qu'on va sortir du mode
du système de bonus malus les
entreprises les plus touchées par la
crise énergétique n'en sommes pas là
aujourd'hui nous avons des dispositifs
pour aider les entreprises concernées y
compris l'accès à l'activité partielle
globalement et de ce que nous savons de
ces entreprises là ce ne sont pas
nécessairement les entreprises qui ont
pu recours à des contrats courts et si
malheureusement licenciement il y avait
c'est plutôt des contrats longs qui
prendrai fin et qui n'auraient pas
d'impact sur le calcul du bonus malus
mais en tout cas soyez assuré que sur
ces secteurs relatifs à l'énergie nous
sommes extrêmement
attentifs je termine par c'est un peu
télégraphique mais j'ai compris la
contrainte de temps par France
compétence pour répondre à Madame Ferret
et ça me permet de répondre à un écho
que j'ai entendu de Monsieur Vandenberg
sur les primes à l'apprentissage
France compétences aujourd'hui étant
déficit c'est une certitude et ça c'est
difficile s'explique par l'augmentation
très importante du nombre d'apprentisses
qui est une bonne nouvelle ça se traduit
par des niveaux de prise en charge des
coûts de formation que nous revoyons
avec un traitement au cas par cas qui
assure Carole et ses équipes pour 4000
et 10000 formations pour lesquelles les
acteurs nous ont dit que l'évolution
était un peu trop rapide et qu'il
fallait la revoir ça s'explique par le
fait que nous sommes passés d'une aide
du nickel embauche de 3000 euros par
apprenti un système à 5000 et à 8000 et
moi je veux bien et là c'est l'ancien
ministre du Budget qui parle plus que le
ministre du Travail mais je veux bien
qu'on nous dise qu'il faut rétablir les
comptes dans le même temps on peut pas
rester sur des tels niveaux
d'intervention donc on va trouver la
bonne angle et le bon niveau pour
maintenir la dynamique tout en revenant
à quelque chose de plus soutenable en
123 France compétence va consacrer
encore plus de 10 milliards d'euros à
l'apprentissage je ne connais je connais
peu de budget sectoriel qui soit aussi
importants et mais il faut prendre ce
compétence revienne à l'équilibre on le
fait revenir à l'équilibre ça n'est pas
que des subventions d'État c'est aussi
du recalibrage et si j'ai bien entendu
qu'on aurait votre soutien pour avoir
plus de subventions de l'État pour
France compétences j'appelle aussi le
votre pour que la régulation qu'on va
mettre en place permet de garder
l'efficacité tout en revenant à quelque
chose de de plus soutenable parce qu'on
ne tiendra pas avec mes 12 à 13
milliards d'euros par an sur
l'apprentissage dans les années qui
viennent
madame Grandchamp pour compléter les
réponses oui très rapidement madame le
présidente pour répondre à Monsieur
lacovelli sur l'accompagnement des
jeunes et des difficultés à
l'orientation et finalement parfois au
décrochage de certains
d'entre eux l'idée évidemment est
d'accompagner cette capacité à mieux
s'orienter au travers de la découverte
des métiers dès la 5ème cette année sous
forme d'expérimentation dans les
collèges et que nous souhaitons élargir
mais également ça a déjà été également
porté au travers des secondes familles
de métiers qui ont été développés dans
les lycées professionnels et les 3e
prépas métiers qui permettent aussi de
mieux préparer l'orientation notamment
vers la voie professionnelle et puis
comme je le disais tout à l'heure cette
prépa apprentissage qui a véritablement
pour vocation d'aller accompagner des
publics véritablement les plus éloignés
des dispositifs de formation et
d'insertion dans l'emploi pour
travailler avec le projet et mieux les
accompagner dans celui-ci avec un taux
de réussite à 60% et qui compte tenu des
des profils et est intéressant mais
également des obligations dont vous
savez de formation des 16-18 et des
accompagnements du coup fait à cet effet
je voudrais répondre à Monsieur Milon
contre concernant
les formations des infirmiers en
pratique avancées la formation elle peut
être financée par les régions par la NFH
par ou par l'employeur des discussions
sont actuellement engagées avec les
fédérations des employeurs pour
faciliter l'accès à la formation et
notamment à l'apprentissage vers le
métier d'infirmière et d'être soignant
ce qui permettra une meilleure prise en
charge de la formation et donc donner
une plus grande attractivité de cette
filière notamment par l'intervention des
employeurs
je voudrais
je reviendrai pas sur la réponse
apportée à même grunie mais
véritablement notre volonté elle est
d'accompagner l'apprentissage de
soutenir l'apprentissage dans un enjeu
de maîtrise budgétaire mais
véritablement de cet objectif du million
d'apprentis
madame guidez sur la VAE et l'approche
j'ai envie de dire
adéquationniste de la VAE que vous avez
évoqué nous souhaitons véritablement
permettre à l'accès à toutes les
certifications qui sont en lien avec
leur parcours professionnel ou personnel
leur engagement doit pouvoir être mieux
reconnu aussi dans les savoir-être
qu'ils ont pu développer dans leur
parcours des dents et c'est bien dans
cette idée là que nous sommes c'est que
évidemment tout ou partie d'une d'un
diplôme ou d'une certification peut-être
effectuée et donc dans leur parcours des
dents bien sûr les métiers du soin
peuvent être une orientation possible
mais pas seulement et évidemment selon
le titre diplôme visé leur parcours leur
permettra de valider tout ou partie de
celui-ci quand bien même il n'est pas
sur les métiers du soir concernant enfin
l'Observatoire sur l'île maîtrise je
tiens à dire qu'il a été placé au sein
de la nlcie que l'objectif est bien de
permettre à l'agence et à tous les
acteurs de l'éducation et de la
formation d'avoir des données
fiabilisées actualisées territorialisée
donc il n'y a aucune concurrence avec
avec l'an SCI mais au contraire un
renforcement de son rôle
merci Madame la Ministre merci monsieur
le ministre et on se dit à bientôt
à bientôt